[Applause]
of our very exclusive club it's very
annoying to other people but we just
don't seem to age no I am but you aren't
what's in the water like what are you no
you know I go I don't know I just that
you're very nice by the way um I pack
real oily skin I'm like if you took a
piece of fried chicken just wipe that on
my face you're the same oh my gosh it's
well it's real different Mario I was
there when you did it's funny because I
remember I was in the audience you did
walk on by it was Burt Bacharach night
yeah you killed it because I was
supposed to do anyone who had a heart
and then at the last minute we were just
so tired then my voice was so tired that
one other one but I love it cuz Aretha
had done it okay you're hosting access
now and he's transitioned from extra so
what's out yeah I'm so excited to be
part of the NBC family and yeah we've
got Access Hollywood
Access daily and all-access and what's
cool about it is we're the only show
that goes live so we're giving you the
latest up-to-the-minute headlines
whatever's going on in the world of
entertainment literally as it's
happening going live all over so which
which there's such an energy to that and
it's and it's obviously incredibly
topical but it's like a great team over
there and we're having a lot of fun and
then in the day it's fun it's fun and
then you know when you're getting done
though you know but then during the day
too it's it's it's cool because we focus
on um I always say civilians like real
people like human interest stories for
People magazine was back in the day and
yeah and what's important a lot of moms
out there and families I mean I got
three kids yeah you know my co-host has
three kids as well and I mean you got
four and so a balancing life and work so
I'm just I feel very blessed and having
a great time it is a balanced
you're married and the kids have my kids
their activities their schedules like
busier than mine
I know you know I mean I know I like to
keep them busy cuz I don't want them to
get in trouble my mom's philosophy with
me she playin that's why I was the only
like dancing karate wrestler theater kid
I knew every day because growing up in
Chula Vista wasn't exactly most upscale
neighborhood there's a lot of potential
get in trouble so she'd get me busy I
don't have time for everything you say
about yourself just makes you cooler
than all of us every time you gotta join
you took dance that must have been like
a cool thing for chicks they were like
oh hey he dances well you know I to be
honest I got teased a lot because I
really I was usually the only boy so
yeah so that's thank God my husband
became a cheerleader so he couldn't be
the only that's why I was also wrestling
and doing everything else too but I
didn't want to quit because you know it
costs money and for my mom and I don't
want to disappoint my mom and you know
and let her down and then I'm glad I
didn't cuz then I found out that women
like guys I know how to move yes
gia and Dominic and Santino
oh yeah he's like brand-new he's so
choose my most chilled out baby so far
so that's the first day at school right
there so the two kids are going G and
Devon are going to the same school I
love that they get to wear uniforms to
meet school in a uniform cuz it's hell
deciding on oh my girl then you're not
to worry about keeping up with the
Joneses and stuff it's just like that's
what you're wearing and that's that when
my daughter doesn't do that she's just
like punky brewster she'll expose
mix-match to kill herself yeah but my
Mimi's always like oh my I have to walk
in with that I love that that's that's
so awesome but you posted a video
telling your older kids that they were
getting a baby brother let's see it you
ready to find out what you're having
[Music]
you're having do you still get for exact
hurry you can still protect a little
brother what she got from that is I have
no competition
you know we waited on all three of the
kids to find out we were having took
some convincing
initially with my wife but then she
loved it it's so you know it's you're
excited I mean see the poor girls sound
like oh it's a monkey it's not still get
a euphoric feeling and we just I just we
didn't tell the kids either until until
like we got home from the hospital so
that's one me I recorded them and I and
this one anybody pregnant out there it's
awesome to wait by the way I'm just
sorry you probably feel horrible it's
great they're great when they come out
you look G Anika are they helping out
with yeah they're obsessed with the baby
right now and Gia Chevy she's only eight
but she's such a great little helper
she's like it's like I have a little
nanny that I don't have to pay it's
great nice so you know and she'll feed
them she'll take care and then my my son
Dominic can't wait to start taking them
to wrestling and jiu-jitsu so yeah it
was up to me I keep having them my wife
says hey you can keep having them but
but I love it I like the chaos you know
we had the dog as a kid everybody
running around so I like it I like a big
family - I think it's not I think as I
grew up not with my family I was only
really with my mom so it's like I didn't
grow up on my brothers and sisters and I
think that's why I love it very much
right now with ours and I want more and
my husband's like no yeah because we
have four but your kids are also on your
radio show - you involve them at work
right yeah well I do the show with my
wife actually on with Mario by the way
you're checking it out sitting yeah so
it's cool so
I love working with it Julie comes like
a couple days a week and we bank the
segments yeah so cause she probably
killed me about it you know every day
right there but it's fun we got the
whole family in on the act the kids
uh-oh she's interviewing I think Adam
Levine in that particular clip right
there she loves me room five but my kids
also do movie reviews and if the rated R
then they just watch the trailer they do
unseen movie reviews it's pretty funny
but she's done Gia's done red carpet
interviewed everyone from like the rock
to what yeah Ellen to everyone that's
amazing so she gia also has I love G&G
also has a side hustle I'm aware of she
like sells her drawing and does she's a
little entrepreneur she had to sell her
little artwork and she negotiates
everything and so I love running a
studio one day or something well there
is one piece of artwork that I really
really love that I want to get to like
the Tooth Fairy thing I saw at the gram
okay this letter is magical and I want
us to put it up
dear Tooth Fairy over the years you have
given me money because I've given you my
teeth this year I would kindly ask
kindly I would kindly ask you if I could
keep my teeth please circle yes or no
and did she heart say yes thank you for
your generosity I always say manners are
so important I teach my kids the most
important words are please thank you
you're welcome and excuse me so it's and
I won't answer them unless they start
with that sentence but yeah she was
trying to basically hit her up for more
money I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this